I HAVE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
BERNIE AND HILLARY AND TRUMP
THIS WEEK.
BUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH JEB
EXCLAMATION POINT?
(LAUGHTER)
TIME TO CHECK IN ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE
UNBLACKENING -- EXCLAMATION
POINT!
♪♪
ON TUESDAY NIGHT, JEB
EXCLAMATION POINT GAVE A BIG
FOREIGN POLICY SPEECH FOCUSING
ON THE MIDDLE EAST.
SHOULD BE INTERESTING.
JEB IS A MAN OF THE WORLD.
AFTER ALL, IN HALF OF HIS SIGNS,
HE'S KNOWN AS "YEB."
OKAY.
HIT ME, UNNECESSARY PUNCTUATION
MAN.
>> NO LEADER OR POLICY-MAKER
INVOLVED WILL CLAIM TO HAVE
GOTTEN EVERYTHING RIGHT IN THE
REGION, IRAQ ESPECIALLY.
>> Larry: OH, SNAP!
JEB EXCLAMATION POINT IS ABOUT
TO CALL OUT HIS OWN BROTHER.
THIS IS LIKE CAIN AND ABEL!
WELL, IT'S THE BUSHES, SO IT'S
MORE LIKE THAT TIME NILES
BETRAYED FRASIER BY REPLACING
HIS CAMEMBERT WITH AN
UNDERWHELMING BRIE.
(APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT, THIS IS EXCITING.
LET'S SEE HOW BRUTAL HE GETS
TOWARDS OLD W.
>> YET, IN A LONG EXPERIENCE
THAT INCLUDES FAILURES OF
INTELLIGENCE AND MILITARY
SETBACKS, ONE MOMENT STANDS OUT
IN MEMORY AS THE TURNING POINT
WE HAD ALL BEEN WAITING FOR --
>> Larry:... YOUR BROTHER
LEAVING OFFICE?
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
DAMN, JEB, YOU COLD!
>> -- AND THAT WAS THE SURGE OF
MILITARY AND DIPLOMATIC
OPERATIONS THAT TURNED EVENTS
TOWARDS VICTORY.
>> Larry: VICTORY?
I DON'T, UH, REMEMBER --
>> Larry: REVISIONEST HISTORY
ALERT.
HISTORY HAS BEEN REWRITTEN.
HUH-OH, GUYS.
WE'RE IN DANGER OF HISTORY BEING
REVISED.
THAT'S OUR REVISIONIST HISTORY
ALERT.
WHAT ARE WE IN FOR?
>> IT WAS A SUCCESS.
SO WHY WAS THE SUCCESS OF THE
SURGE FOLLOWED BY A WITHDRAWAL
FROM IRAQ, CREATING THE VOID
THAT I.S.I.S. MOVED IN TO FILL?
WHERE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE
CLINTON IN ALL OF THIS?
>> Larry: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA!
SO GEORGE IS GONE, AND IT'S ALL
HILLARY'S PROBLEM NOW?
WHAT KIND OF DISTORTED REALITY
ARE YOU LIVING IN?
THIS IS SOME DOC BROWN MARTY
McFLY TIME TRAVEL REALNESS
RIGHT NOW.
"WHERE WE'RE GOING, WE DON'T
NEED FACTS!"
(APPLAUSE)
>> LIKE THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF,
SHE HAD OPPOSED THE SURGE, THEN
JOINED IN CLAIMING CREDIT FOR
ITS SUCCESS.
WHO CAN SERIOUSLY ARGUE THAT
AMERICA AND OUR FRIENDS ARE
SAFER TODAY THAN IN 2009?
>> Larry: OH, YOU WANT TO PLAY
THE "SAFER THAN" GAME?
YOU WANT THE PLAY THE "SAFER
THAN" GAME?
BECAUSE I THINK MOST AMERICANS
FELT A LOT SAFER IN THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION THAN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
2009?
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DROP A
DATE -- I'VE GOT SEPTEMBER 11
RIGHT HERE IN MY POCKET.
YOU WANT ME TO TAKE IT OUT?!
DIDN'T THINK SO.
YOU WERE SAYING ABOUT THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM IRAQ,
MR. EXCLAMATION POINT?
>> IT WAS A CASE OF BLIND HASTE
TO GET OUT AND CALL THE TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCES SOMEBODY ELSE'S
PROBLEM.
RUSHING AWAY FROM DANGER CAN BE
EVERY BIT AS UNWISE AS RUSHING
INTO DANGER.
>> Larry: NO, IT CAN'T!
THAT'S NOT A THING!
YOU DON'T RUN INTO A HOUSE FIRE
AND THEN TAKE YOUR TIME GETTING
OUT.
YOU DO THE THING YOU WENT IN
THERE TO DO -- SAVE YOUR
COLLECTION OF VINTAGE
PORNOGRAPHY -- AND YOU GET OUT!
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
SO THEN YESTERDAY, WHEN JEB WAS
ASKED ABOUT HIS IRAQ ATTACK ON
THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE, HE
SAID THIS --
"I'M NOT ATTACKING HER," BUSH
"I'M JUST POINTING OUT THAT THE
FOREIGN POLICY THAT THEY HAVE
IMPLEMENTED WAS ONE THAT CREATED
A MORE DANGEROUS WORLD."
YEAH,
"I'M NOT ATTACKING HER, I'M
HUGGING THE FACT THAT SHE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL
THE EVIL IN THE WORLD."
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE TO ME, THAT
JEB -- EXCLAMATION (BLEEP) POINT
BUSH -- ACTUALLY HAD THE GALL TO
MAKE IT SEEM LIKE THIS (BLEEP)
IN THE MIDDLE EAST WAS NOT
STARTED BY HIS BROTHER.
AND FOR THE RECORD, JEB EVEN
ADMITS HE WOULD HAVE DONE IT,
TOO.
>> ON THE SUBJECT OF IRAQ,
OBVIOUSLY VERY CONTROVERSIAL,
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW NOW, WOULD
YOU HAVE AUTHORIZED THE
INVASION?
>> I WOULD HAVE, AND SO WOULD
HAVE HILLARY CLINTON, JUST TO
REMIND EVERYBODY.
>> Larry: NO, NO, NO.
STOP TRYING TO DRAG HILLARY INTO
THIS.
THAT'S HORRIBLE.
BASICALLY, YOUR BROTHER TOOK A
BIG STINKING DUMP, DIDN'T FLUSH,
(APPLAUSE)
RIGHT?
THAT'S WHAT IT'S LIKE!
HATE TO BE GRAPHIC, LADIES, I
APOLOGIZE --
BROKE THE TOILET, YOU ADMIT YOU
WOULD HAVE DONE THE SAME -- AND
NOW YOU'RE TRYING TO BLAME IT ON
THE NICE LADY WHO'S DELETING HER
E-MAILS DOWN THE HALL.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT!